[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar
bu tedox'larda TED konuşmalarında
biliyoruz ki siz biliyor musunuz
bilmiyorum ama ben de bunu merak edip
öğrendim aslında herkes gelip kendi
deneyimlerimi kendi tecrübelerini gelip
bu Yuvarlağın içinden pek ayrılmadan
anlatırlar Yani bizim gibi siyam ikisi
gibi çıkan çok az Biz pipisia 5-6 yıl
önce bağladık bilmiyorum seyrediyor
musunuz 5-6 yıl önce Küba gezisi ile
başlayan bir serüvenimiz var Erkan
Can'la
o günden bugüne çeşitli ülkenin çeşitli
yerlerini dünyanın çeşitli yerlerini
gerek karavanla gerek uçakla gerek başka
araçlarla gezerek seyahat programları
yapıyoruz burada bir konuşma yapmamız
teklif edildiğinde bize üzerine düşündük
çok da Öyle düşünen fazla insanlarda
değiliz aslında yani çok daha spontan
götürüyoruz her şeyimizi Bu akşam da
biraz Komutanım olacak Ne konuşalım
Oradan mı buradan mı derken aslında
bildiğimiz alandan biraz oyunculuktan
konuşalım istedik oyunculuk meselesi her
zaman geçer Akça olmuştur hayatta
oyunculuk hep geçerek ama artarak giden
bir grafiği olduğunu Ama mesela bizim
gençlik yıllarımızda oyunculuk o kadar
geçer akçe değildi mesela
Ebeveynler anneler babalar çocuklarının
oyuncu olmalarını pek Arzu etmezlerdi ne
yapacaksın aç kalırsın yavrum falan diye
ha sen gene tiyatronunu yap Hobi olarak
He şimdi de mesleğin olsun yani şimdi de
Ee yani bu işten para kazanmak çok zor
rekabet arttı rekabet arttı Şimdi de
başka bir zorluklar çıktı piyasaya zor
Yani ilk 30 senesi çok zor Evet öyle bir
laf vardır bizim aramızda konuştuğumuz
oyuncuların oyunculuğun ilk 30 senesi
zor derler Biz çok şükür kafasına atmış
durumdadır Aslında her işte öyle yani
bir mesleğe başladığınızda Hemen olmuyor
yani En az bir 20 sene zaten geçiyor
Yani çıraklık kalfalık ustalık Al sana
30 sene ya öyle oldu 25 sene Evet her
işte Ama bizim tiyatrocular için
söylenir bu onu da ilk altener Bulak
söylemiştir rahmetli ilk 30 senesi çok
zordur yavrum demiş e doğru söylemiş
Altan abi de Yani
oyunculuk mesleğine aynı oranda geri
ödüyor oyunculuk da öyle yani yarım
yamalak hakikaten yapılacak bir iş değil
full konsantre yapımı yapman gereken bir
iş Yani bir iş yapayım hakikaten
oyunculuğu da hobi gibi yapayım bir şey
söz konusu değil ama biz bunu
ailelerimize o zamanlar çok bunu
anlatmakta kifayetli olamadık Bugün
artık Ebeveynler kendileri çocukları
oyuncu olsun diye ellerinden tutup kas
ajanslarının kapılarını aşındırıyorlar
oyuncu olmaları için anne babalar artık
ekstra eforlar sarf ediyorlar bizim
zamanımız öyle zamanlar değildi Ben
Oyuncu olabilmek için gerçekten çok
mücadele verdim Erkan abi de birazdan
oyunculuk macerasından bahsedecek onu da
ilginç bir macerası var
bugün karşınızda bir oyuncu aktör Erkan
Can olarak
duramayabilirdi tam da birazdan
anlatacağı şeyleri dinledikten sonra siz
de öyle olduğunu göreceksiniz benim
maceramda da ben gerçekten büyük bir
mücadele verdim Oyuncu olabilmek için
Evden kaçtım falan yani bildiğiniz
kafayı çok koydum bu işe çok inandım
başka bir meslek yapmak gibi bir şey
asla aklımdan geçmedi kaldı ki benim
Mimar olmam bekleniyordu benden Mesela
daha öncesinde de böyle bir girişimimde
olmuştu o fakülteye falan yani Mimar
olmak Evet benim Mimarlık hala çok büyük
bir ilgi alanım mimarlıktan hala çok
keyif alıyorum Ee bir yerlerde hep
Beyoğlu'nda falan yürürken İstanbul'da
arkadaşlarımı tutup şu apartmana Bakın
şu apartmana bakın diyorum bana
manasızca bakıyorlar yani Mimarlık hala
benim gönlümde çok sevdiğim bir alan ama
oynamazsam sahnede olmazsam sanki
olmayacak gibi hissettiğim için tutkuyla
bunun peşine düştüm ezcümle bir yerden
sonra da zaten Eee muvaffak oldum ama
III üç yıl konservatuvar sınavlarına
girdim mesela gerçekten bir Azim
hikayesi olarak anlatabilirim bunu
yılmadım 1 yıl girdim 5-600 kişi sınava
giriyorsunuz nihayetinde 12 kişi
alıyorlar ama iki aşamalı olduğu için
önce 22 kişi alıyorlar kazanıyor sınavı
soru 20 kişi bir daha sınava giriyor
okula giriyorsunuz ben her seferinde
20'nin içindeydim 12 ila ediliyordu
12'nin içinde değildim biraz da soyadlı
insanlar da var dosyada Onlar da benim
yüzümü açıkça söylenmiş oldu yani
soyadlardan kastım şu; birinin yeğeni
öbürünün oğlu öbürünün kızı Eee böyle
şeyler olabiliyor Tabii bir şey söz
konusu olduğunda bir şeyi tarttıklarında
o öğrenciyim bu çocuğumu alayım falan
diye baktıklarında
ebeveynlerin içinde bir tiyatrocu olan
oyuncu olan varsa onlar Biraz daha belki
aileden dolayı torpilli oluyorlar
doğallığından ben işte O iki sene
boyunca onları çok ee şey yapamadım Ee
geçemedim ve O iki sene boyunca da ama
vazgeçmedim 3 yıl tekrar çalıştım tekrar
büyük bir azimle gerçekten Çünkü ben bu
mesleği yapmazsam mutlu olamayacağım
kanaatine çoktan varmıştım ta lisede
öğrenciyken oradan başlayan bir süreçti
çok konuştum Erkan abi Senin de gemi
Hikayen var gemiyi hikayeye Ee var da
yani yol uzun ben 16 yaşında başladım
burada
Bursa devlet tiyatrosunda
feraycizade Mehmet Şakir Bey gençlik
Tiyatrosu kurusunda başladık kurs
hocaların devlet tiyatrosunda oynayan
abilerim ablalarım hocalarım onlarla
başladım orada
bir konservatuvar gibi bir Kursumuz
vardı yani şu anda o kurs eski hocalarla
birlikte O dönemki
şu anda bütün
konservatuvarlardan çok daha iyi eğitim
veriyordu bizim temelimiz Bursa
dağıtıldı mahallede atıldığı mahalledeki
abilerim
Bursa Mesken
meskenliğim ben Esas kütüğüm Ali Paşa
Mahallesi kuzgunluk Somuncu babanın
Sokağı bütün sülalemin oturduğu
dedemlerin
efendime söyleyeyim Hani Bursa'da
olduğumuz için onların nereden
bahsettiğimi biliyorlar Onun için
mahalledeki abilerim dediler Sen taklit
matlit yapıyorsun kahvede şurada burada
hep abilerimle dolaşıyorum onların
yanına gidiyorum
seviyorlardı Beni beni devlet
tiyatrosunun haberim yok Ben Bursa'ya
meskenden gitmiyorum ki bir saatte bir
arabamız var otobüsümüz var yani
Bursa'nın dışı bir yer
devlet tiyatrosunda dediler kurs var git
dilekçeni ver buraya yazıl iki tane
fotoğraf çektir Karadağ fotoğrafçısında
efendime söyleyeyim oradan İki vesikalık
yaptık
çektik dilekçemizi verdik kurslara
sınavlara girdik
sınavları kazandık o zaman sınav
dediğimiz durumlar işte yavru ile
Katibin taklidi Nejat Uygur'un taklidi
sinemadan gördüklerimiz şeyleri
yapıyoruz
kursa başladık
1973-74 sezonunda
o kursu bitirdik sonra ben çiftlik iş
gidiyor Yıldırım Beyazıt Lisesi
efendime söyleyeyim sana Akşam Sanat
yeni yol endüstri meslek lisesini
kazandık metal bölümü
sürekli boykot olduğu için de orada hep
devamsızlıktan kaldı gece benim devlet
tiyatrosunda 7 tane oyunda küçük irili
ufaklı rollerim var gece okulu tiyatro
var
Babam da istiyor ki babam da
Arif'i mezunu bir öğretmen
tiyatroya bir şey demiyor
Adamcağız kaçıyorum okullardan kaçıyorum
oyuna gidiyorum Çünkü dersleri yarım
bırakıyorum okul gece
insanlar böyle bir tavırlı sert bir
şeyleri olan ilçeleri olanlar Onun için
babam da ipin ucunu bıraktı sonra
teneke askerliğim geldi 5 sene askerden
kaçtık okul vardı o vardı bu vardı en
sonunda
askere gittik Sonra ben artık tiyatro
bütün arkadaşlarım konservatuvara gitmiş
Zafer al göz Ali Sürmeli okullar
kazanmış Ben lise mezunu olmadığım için
lise 2 terkis işte devamsızlıklardan
kaldık bu durumda
[Müzik]
yaşım büyük diye Olmadı Sonra kağıtta
bir en altta ince bir yazı var böyle
oraya okuduk sınıf atlama seviye sınavı
üstün yetenek sınavı ona hazırlandım Ben
Prosedür olarak
işte 3 gün 5 gün bir vakit var çok az
bir vakit gittim Bursa'ya geldim Ertan
akman'la birlikte
rozenbergler Ölmemeli oyununun şitır
gibi yaptık kısalttık
sahneleri iki kişilik zaten
o oyunu oynadım onunla birlikte
sınavı geçtim Yıldız Kenter beni 3
sınıftan aldı sen dedi üçüncü sınıftan
geliyor yavrum dedi hocam dedim ben
müsaade edersiniz birden okumak
istiyorum dedim birden başladım
Yani tabii ki bu yıllarımızı aldı Sonra
tiyatro
gemiye bilseydin teknik gemiye binseydin
olmasaydı
benim hayatımda böyle arkadaşlar son
vagon son tren son vagana hep hayatım
boyunca öyle atlamış tutturmuş gitmiş
oyunculuk meselesi ile ilgili çok
belirleyici bir şey söylemek isterim
mesela askerdeyken komutan gelir
sivildeyken kaç kişi duvar ustası der
seçerler 15 kişi öne çıkar biz duvar
ustasıyız Efendim komutanım diye
komutan der ki işte elektrikçi der
12 kişilik çıkar biz elektrikçiyiz
efendim
müsamere yapacağız Çocuklar kim çıkar
müsamere eder bütün Bölük öne çıkar
bütün Bölük
Ya ben elektrikçi değilim elektrikten
anlamam öne çıksam elektrik işi verseler
çarpılırım olmaz yani öyle bir meslek
yapıyoruz ki aslında bir taraftan da
herkesin kendinde bir parça Hadi bulduğu
özellikle bugünlere bakarsak biraz daha
erozyona uğramış bir iş yapıyoruz
aslında oyunculuk mesleği Hemen herkesin
Aslında biraz belagati varsa hop ne var
canım bunu ben de yaparım diye çok
kolayından Zaten herkes dizi oyuncusu
olmak istiyor kimse böyle olmuyor yani
gerçek manada oyuncu olmakla gerçek
manada tiyatrocu olmakla falan kimse pek
alakalı değil daha çok hakikaten meşhur
olmakla daha çok köşeyi dönmekle Ee daha
çok para kazanıyor olması sevdasıyla bu
mesleğe giriyorlar Ama bu meslek öyle
bir meslek değil bu meslek hakikaten
biraz meşakkatli ve zor bir meslek Şaka
bir yana ilk 30 yıldız var ama aslında
bütünü çok zor her seferinde
değişebilmek zor Çünkü her seferinde
değişmekle karşı karşıya lazım tabii
yani Ee siz de bilmiyorsunuz paletinizde
ne kadar renk var siz de kendiniz ne
kadar değişebileceğinize dair tam olarak
bir fikir sahibi değilseniz ama sizden
beklenen
bir şiiri var mesela oyunculara kasten
söylediği çıkın gün ışığına
değişebilenler diyor Biz
değişebildiğimiz için bu melekimiz
geliştiği için bize bir takım insanlar
yani yapımcı sıfatıyla paralar ödüyorlar
diyorlar ki Erkan Bey şu parayı alın
bize pilotmuşsunuz gibi davranın Güven
Bey Şimdi siz şu parayı alın bize
doktormuşsunuz gibi davranın Biz de o
paraları alıyoruz mesleğimiz bu olduğu
için alıyoruz
mış gibi yapıyoruz yani bir şeyi Eğer
bir önce yaptığına benziyorsa bir önce
pilotmuşsun gibi yaptığınla bir sonra
parasını alıp doktormuşsun gibi yaptığın
üç aşağı beş yukarı benzerlik
gösteriyorsa orada bir sıkıntı var
demektir orada bir sorun var demektir
Bunlar da mesleğin incelikleri Ee
bunları niye anlatıyoruz Belki de
hakikaten İçinizde oyuncu olması Sevdası
da olan oyuncu olmak isteyen veya
oyunculuk mesleğini merak eden bütün bu
detayları öğrenmiş olmaktan dolayı
kendini iyi ve mutlu hissedebilecek
insanlar vardır diye Bütün bunlardan
bahsediyoruz Bir de dediğimiz gibi
oyunculuk meselesi Aslında daha
saatlerce konuşabiliriz bizim En iyi
bildiğiniz en iyi anlattığımız meslek
yapamıyoruz yapsak ticaretten anlamayız
bilgi denememiz oldu ama sonuçlandı
Ağzımızın payını aldık Yani en iyi
Bildiğin iş neyse onu yapacak onu yapmak
lazım yani profesyonel alanlara Saygılı
olmak lazım tabii ki bizim mesleğimiz
kimsenin ipoteğinde değil dileyen herkes
resim de yapabilir dans da edebilir
şarkı da söyleyebilir Dolayısıyla
oyunculuk da yapabilir kimsenin
ipoteğinde değil dediğim gibi ama yeter
ki bir takım küçük minik kriterler var
onları yerine getirebilsin onlardan bir
tanesi ve en önemlisi ne Evet belli bir
oranda belli bir düzeyde yeteneğin olsun
bir kere Evet
bu mecbur
sonra Bu mesleğin yani her mesleğin
kendi saygınlıkları var o saygınlıkları
o ettiğine uymak gerekir Bu mesleğin eti
yine Bu mesleğin kurallarına uygun
davranış geliştir Başka da bir şey yok
seyirciden kabul görürsen zaten Yani bu
bir alışveriş meselesi Siz bir şey
yapıyorsunuz onlar kabul ediyorlarsa
bitmiştir yani o Konsensus sağlanmış
demek karşılıklı Tabii Her işin temeli
bu işin temeli de özellikle
okumaktan geçiyor kendini bu konuda hep
geliştirmekten geçiyor
okumadığımız zaman oyunculuk 2 tane rol
çıkartırsın üçüncüsü çıkmaz silinir
gidersin o yüzden okumak bu işin temeli
ve oradan yenilenir insan yeniden
küllerinden doğar
okumak insana büyük kapılar açar büyük
pencereler açar vizyonu genişler insanın
oyunculuk birebir tamam ıyla Okumakla
ilintili bir şey
Yanlış mıyım Çok doğru okumadan mümkün
değil zaten Yani tabii ki ama her alanda
var yani her alan doktorsanız da sürekli
okumak zorunda
mezun olduğum Doktor oldum diye bitmiyor
ki o işler bir sürü alanda bir sürü
mesleğin şeyi serüveni öyle bitmiyor
mimarsınız da bitmiyor
doktorsanız da oyuncuysanız da bir sürü
meslek var ki onlar okulları bitirdikten
sonra biten meslekler değil değerli
vaktinizi aldık Çok teşekkür ederiz
bizleri dinlediğiniz için umarız
bir parça da olsa oyunculukla ilgili
kafanızda bazı şeylerin oturmasına ilham
olmuştur Sağ olun var olun Çok teşekkür
ederiz yani
son bir şey Belki Buyurun yani iyi bir
tiyatro seyircisi olmak Yani şimdi
gençlere hep herkes Oyuncu olmak istiyor
ya Ama iyi bir tiyatro seyircisi olmak
iyi bir oyuncu olmaktan daha iyidir
onu takip etmekte olmak da çok kıymetli
bir şeydir içinde olmak onunla
ilgilenmek onunla
haşır neşir olmak Çünkü oyuncuyu oynatan
seyircidir iyi bir seyirci olursa burada
biz de oyuncularda sizlere çok muhteşem
oyunlar muhteşem duygular sunabiliriz
teşekkürler
Sağ ol eyvallah